hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well one of the
key set of ideas that we see of
Paramount importance in most of the
schools of ancient philosophy is an
orientation towards what they often
called one of the ends of life the good
and namely eudaimonia or happiness and
they conceived of this in multiple ways
happiness for an Epicurean isn't exactly
the same as it is for an Aristotelian
let alone a cynic and another thing that
goes along with this for most of these
schools of philosophy is a commitment to
what we often translate as virtue or
moral excellence
in Greek and you know we're not going to
quibble about how exactly to get it
across but the idea is that there's a
way of being that's particularly good
and it can often be broken down into a
number of subdivisions and one common
way of doing that that the cynics seem
to more or less have followed along with
is to talk in terms of wisdom or
practical wisdom Justice Temperance or
moderation self-control courage and
these included other things so for
example you're going to see that the
cynics also talk a lot about
self-control and kratiya in Greek or
endurance
right and those might be located in
terms of temperance and courage they do
involve Justice and wisdom as well and
what we get in the letters attributed to
kratase are a number of really
interesting discussions having to do
with these virtues these virtues that
need to be developed and also devices
vices are the opposite of Virtues the
bad qualities that need to be rooted out
of people and so a good place to begin
is with letter three which is addressed
to his students right and um actually
sorry yeah letter three take care of
your soul right so this is a very common
idea in ancient Greek philosophy melato
who mean tastes suitcase give care give
concern to your soul but he says also
take care of the body to the degree that
necessity requires and external things
not even that much why
happiness eudaimonia is not pleasure it
is
virtue instead pleasure makes us need
external things uh you know the things
that produce that pleasure wine if we're
if we're going to drink opportunities to
spend money if that's what we're into
doing retail therapy as they call it
virtue doesn't require that virtue he
says is complete without any externals
it is talaya it can be brought to its
fruition you can be a just person and be
totally destitute and you can still be
just or courageous or wise or temperate
so that's an important lesson that he's
giving his students in letter seven he's
going to talk about the cynic way of
life as freeing people from evils and
he's actually this is a very interesting
letter it's addressed to the wealthy
toys the rich people right and he says
you've got all this stuff but you act
like complete jerks you're guilty of
treachery you exercise tyranny you
commit murder you perpetuate whatever
other things there are despite the fact
that one should instead live in peace
live quietly right
is the the verb there and it literally
means to be at peace right the rich
people they're not happy being rich so
clearly wealth isn't what produces
happiness he says we observe complete
peace why we have been freed from every
evil and I want to dwell on this so
um you know the the word here is pontos
Kaku so bad things wicked things we've
been freed not only of things that are
bad to us but of Badness within
ourselves and this word freed right it's
it's got this so the actual word there
is
we are people who are free we are
genuinely free you think that wealth
brings you Freedom it's actually virtue
that brings you genuine freedom and he's
going to use this term in multiple
letters
um it means to be a free person not a
slave by contrast he talks about
diogenes you know the great hero and in
fact karate's own teacher right in this
letter to patroclus
and it tells us that diogenes himself
exhibited courage which is one of the
virtues in his practice
or his development
right
escasis is
discipline practice development the sort
of thing you have to do day after day
diogenes was courageous Andrea he showed
right in the practice of virtue so
courage interestingly in this model is
needed in order to develop the other
virtues it's not that you have to be
courageous right at the start but you
have to develop courage right and he
also tells us in that letter that
diogenes delivered many
from Evil to Virtue he made it possible
for them to leave
wickedness right uh Vice to Virtue and
he did this both when he was alive and
after he died through his teachings so
this is part of the stoic tradition
another really cool idea that comes up
that others will pick up later in
non-synic circles to talk about the
cynics is this idea and it comes up in a
letter to hipparchia
where karates her husband tells her that
one of the things that the cynics do
that they aim at is being freed of even
nature going Beyond nature and again we
see this this word here
right
and this word is meaning to be raised to
the status of a free person
even from nature from our human nature
to go beyond it to do something greater
why he says because everybody else are
slaves or they labor under either law or
wickedness
um it's either Vice that's driving them
or it's the the law
so in another letter to her he says
reason is a guide of the Soul a
beautiful work it's kalon ergon and the
greatest good to human beings
therefore seek how to acquire this for
yourself then you will hold fast to a
happy life along with this possession of
reason and of virtue and so this is what
the cynic thinks we should do so how do
we develop these virtues well there's
certain letters that give us ideas about
that one of these is that we shouldn't
just like go to the rules of law because
those can help us out in avoiding
wickedness right or avoiding following
the wickedness that's inside of us
but the law can't actually guide us in
how we ought to behave positively
right I mean it can even tell us to do
things that are positive well you're
going to you know uh perform
courageously in Warfare and if you don't
we'll kill you
that doesn't actually make people
courageous that makes them more scared
of being killed by one person than by
being killed another and that you can
command Temperance nobody will consume
more than their fair share of things or
what is you know detrimental to their
body
I mean that's not very effective is the
War on Drugs has shown us right but even
if it were people wouldn't be doing it
necessarily for the right reason
philosophy is what helps us out there
philosophies what guides us towards
virtue there's another fascinating
letter number 10 which is addressed to a
guy lysius and he says I've heard Lucius
you've been constantly drunk ever since
the contest in Eritrea so is this really
the case if it is I'm going to say these
things to you you shouldn't be drinking
that much right
um so he says it it's this is an absurd
way of living
try to learn he doesn't say quit
drinking altogether try to learn to use
it use the wine temperately and in the
company of temperate people so that the
gift of God might not come down on your
head because you dishonor it the wine
the grape is something that the the
world gives us it's wonderful isn't it
but you can do too much with it and so
learn how to be self-controlled and
temperate
he says that
um you know the pleasures that come from
it might be enjoyed without regret and
might be actually beneficial to you
especially now here's the key
when you live decently
which means like well arranged you know
the word schema is in there well
schemaed and justly the chios right if
you do those things then you'll be able
to consume and enjoy temperately
um so he says you know Temperance and
the pleasures that are being limited you
won't do anything indecent or bad in
your life but say and do everything that
is just and he says by their presence
men are said to become Thrice blessed is
three benefits accrue to them in life
how would those men not be blessed who
have temperate Souls this is the most
important part and what what results
from that healthy bodies right bodies
that are not breaking down because
you're drunk all the time and hungover
and sufficient possessions which for the
cynic is actually not that much but
you're not going to be like wasting your
possessions because you want to get
drunk all the time and forget where
things are or you have to spend all your
money on you know your drink talking or
the effects of your drinking a little
bit later in letter 15 addressed to his
students he tells us to shun not only
the worst of Evil's Injustice and
self-indulgence but also their cause is
pleasure you might say well there's a
little bit of tension there isn't it
can't didn't we just find out that you
can enjoy pleasure temperately justly in
an orderly way and and yes but we have
to be very careful with Pleasures
according to the cynics because they do
in fact lead to Injustice to taking more
than our fair share to being greedy
right or to being self-indulgent being
unintemperate right uh being irresolute
the word here is actually a classian a
failure of Will and he says if you
concentrate on these you're going to
concentrate on these alone both present
and future and uh nothing else you're
not going to develop virtue and so he
says pursue not only the best of goods
self-control right being able to be in
charge yourself encration and
perseverance or rather endurance cartean
but also their causes toils toils are
something that comes up over and over in
the letters so it's a way in which you
develop these virtues right you don't
develop virtues without hard work and he
says don't shun them on account of their
harshness or being difficult right so
you know why why would you uh exchange
inferior things for something uh
exchange great things for inferior
things why would you take a bad bargain
in this case do the work the work is not
something you know wonderful in itself
but what do you get virtues right you
receive virtue in exchange for toils he
explicitly says finally there's there's
one other passage that I think is is
really helpful and it's a in
letter 12 he says it's not going to the
country that makes good people or going
to the city that makes bad people right
people sometimes are like oh well you
send somebody here to this culture these
these people going out in the country
that's where the real people are no no
people in the country are just as bad as
people in the city and vice versa he
says it's rather the time that you spend
or the you know things you do with them
the occupations with good people or bad
people so if you want your sons to
become good people not bad people don't
send them to the country that's not
going to help them
send them to the Philosopher's School
send them to into the philosopher right
it's on them at the philosopher why
because there you learn the good things
in life
right and he says virtue is something
acquired by practice right so what kind
of practice are we talking about there
uh escasis and so doing things over and
over and over again eventually you
become virtuous it does not
spontaneously or automatically if we
want to stick very close to the Greek
enter into the soul as Vice does so if
we want to be virtuous again we've got
to be willing to work for it we have to
engage in training discipline practice
escasis and it's probably better if we
do that associating with other people
who similarly view the world and you
know what they want to do with their
lives so this is a sort of a rundown of
what we find out about virtue as the way
to happiness in the cynic Epistles that
are attributed to this guy krates